today is a big day for Britain's
youngest royal that's Prince Louie look
at him he turns one years old today
happy birthday Prince newly got some
teeth in there Kensington Palace
released these photos to mark the
occasion they were taken by his mom the
Duchess of Cambridge that's Kate we're
also waiting news from Prince Harry and
Megan Markel as you know they are
expecting their very first baby it's
unlikely that this new addition to the
royal family will ever rule the UK but
he or she will be seventh in line to the
throne empty as tyub is in windsor near
the couple's home with more on this
story MTS good morning any news not yet
but you know it has to be says that for
centuries royal births have really been
the source of palace and international
intrigue and so when Harry and Megan
decided to ditch with decades of
tradition it did raise a few eyebrows
but it should be said that this isn't
the first time that we've seen
traditions defied ahead of a royal birth
at 93 years young Queen Elizabeth the
second the longest-serving monarch in
British history celebrated her birthday
and style on Sunday topped off with a 41
gun salute but Princess Elizabeth as she
was known when she was born back in 1926
was part of the push to end an awkward
ancient royal birthing protocol her own
home birth had to be witnessed by a
government minister for Fears any
potential heir to the throne could be
swapped out for an impostor here is the
first picture of His Royal Highness
Prince Charles of Edinburgh just four
weeks out Queen Elizabeth's firstborn
son was born by caesarean at buckingham
palace his sister and brothers were born
there too but all of their children
would usher in a new era of hospital
births most famously Prince William
who's the first direct heir to the
British throne to be born in a medical
ward and it was introduced to the world
on the hospital's front steps
Ashley Diana found it very stressful and
then they drove away and the car went
round the corner
she burst into tears but two years later
she faced the photographer's again after
the birth of Prince Harry at a couple of
decades later Prince William and Kate
the Duchess of Cambridge introduced
their first child George on the very
same steps but now the rules of
succession have changed allowing
Princess Charlotte the next child to
maintain her position ahead of her
younger brother Prince Louie who was
born a few years later Harry and Megan
are choosing to have a much more private
birth closer to their home in Windsor
where they married last year the first
wheel see a bear little one won't be
ours but more likely days after their
arrival it's sad for royal followers
because we all want to enjoy this baby
with them but I think everybody
completely understands their decision
one tradition Harry and Megan are
keeping is we can expect to see that
royal easel placed outside of the gates
of Buckingham Palace announcing the
birth of their firstborn but something
else that might happen more in line with
our modern times is we can also expect a
simultaneous Instagram post as well yeah
yeah you're right I know it's her
decision I hope they don't make us wait
too long but MT has there was news there
this morning from the UK you know what
I'm saying so it was announced that
President Trump has accepted an
invitation from the Queen for a state
visit in June so what do you think we
should expect from that that's right
president Trump has announced that he's
accepted this invitation from the Queen
for a state visit it should be said that
he was first invited by the Prime
Minister Theresa May shortly after he
was elected in 2016 for a state visit he
did come here last year and I think his
visit last year which was described a
working visit is going to be pretty
reflective of what he can expect this
time around which is protests lots of
protests in fact tens of thousands of
people took to the streets to protest
his visit and he can expect the same all
right a lot of news coming from across
the pond in tears tie up in Windsor
thank you